freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlich herr koch
ich bin hier bei falco und ich kann nur
so viel sagen es ist schon ein bisschen
zeit vergangen bevor ich das wieder
angefangen haben mit vorbereitung etc
deshalb seht ihr jetzt erst mal was zum
frühstück gemacht habe nämlich brioche
also italienische frühstücks croissants
mit füllung und dazu ein café aber das
hat ein bisschen gedauert deshalb schaue
ich das gerne
ich habe zunächst 300 gramm mehl in eine
rührschüssel gegeben daraufhin 40 gramm
zucker zehn gramm salz 3 eier dann habe
ich 40 milliliter milch in der
mikrowelle warm gemacht und vier gramm
hefe darin aufgelöst noch ein einzelnes
eigelb rein daraufhin die hefe mischung
und 200 gramm butter auf raumtemperatur
in stückchen hinzugefügten nachdem ich
das ganze gehört hat sodann habe ich das
ganze für drei stunden bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen habe es
danach durchgeknetet und über nacht im
kühlschrank gegeben am nächsten morgen
habe ich die arbeitsfläche gemailt den
teig rund ausgerollt und den acht pizza
stücke geschnitten
dann habe ich die füllung aufgetragen
paar mit nutella ein paar mit marmelade
vorne am pizza steht angefeuchtet
langgezogen und zuhören team geholt dann
ist das ganze für eineinhalb stunden in
den backofen gegeben und hatte nur das
licht an
so sagen die dann aus nach eineinhalb
stunden ein bisschen auseinander
gegangen dann habe ich sie gebacken bei
200 grad für zwölf minuten und dass das
endprodukt sind ein bisschen auseinander
gegangen aber hoppla ich einfach
hiermit kann das ziel
wer die schönsten und ausgestaltung
einer mit nutella einmal mit marmelade
und das was vielleicht nicht ganz
perfekt geworden ist machen wir einfach
dass sogar wieder gut also dann weil wir
immer syrien
[Musik]
es ist soweit ein bruder buck und
elfriede ott dazu ein komma oder selbst
gemacht
ich habe sogar überlegt gehabt dass ich
meine kaffeemaschine h hierher
mitbringen ich habe nämlich so eine
siebträgermaschinen sollten aber dann
dachte ich mir ist vielleicht ein
bisschen zu viel aufwand ich habe
leckeren cappuccino und die branche ich
bin sehr gespannt weil ihr format läuft
es so du beißt einmal da sagst du gar
nicht viel
ok sondern die kameraden aus dann ist du
kannst nur auf und dann gibst du deine
noten von eins bis zehn
aber ich glaube ich weiß wie gut wie es
mein kopf ruhig als letztes mal gesehen
wie man habe jetzt alles von mir fehlen
natürlich auch gespannt ich freue mich
ganz besonders auf dieses video auch
wünschen dass auch italienischer küche
liebe ich diese kraft und jetzt bin ich
gespannt ist noch war ja ist noch warm
dass sich zu risiko du wolltest du ja
also ich würde sagen den kaffee den
cappuccino was richtig delikat uhr lag
etwa hoppe so muss man den tiger
angefangen genauso
das ist das klassische italienische
frühstückstisch zuschauer das ist man
normalerweise in der bank quasi genau
also wenn man so auf dem weg zur arbeit
oder schule oder sollte ich wieder mal
an die theke und cappuccino trinkt man
das also so wie bei passau ein deutscher
ist es komplett anders war so britsch in
leber muskel so dass eine richtige
mahlzeit so richtiges fest appetit also
genau das gegenteil wir so enthüllt aber
dafür wenn die nächsten gänge
richtig airplay leute da habt ihr noch
nie gesehen war das wehr teil auch jetzt
sehr kurz gefasst vom frühstück beim
mittagessen wird alles aus holz auch
richtig gut noch warm
man spürt aber man sieht und man fühlt
auch dass sie mit handgemacht sind also
so nachtigall allem aber weil ich
wirklich etwas merken sollte will ich
sagen sie war das auch laptop ist so ein
bisschen trocken
aber das ist wirklich mclennan auf ganz
ernstes level deswegen will ich sagen
achteinhalb geist ganze serie aber wenn
ich zehn sein würde wenn ich auch nicht
wirklich daran dass die nahrung in
arbeit ist es doch was so heftig ist
also wie sagen erst mal um achteinhalb
so gravenstein und bis zum mittagessen
und wir kommen zum mittagessen leute es
wird drei gerichte zum mittagessen geben
so ist das nämlich klassischerweise in
italien und ich dachte mir kommt für
falsch ich mal keine mühe als prima also
als vorspeise machen wir machen wir
passte form also überbackene passt dafür
muss ich all das hier schneiden da
erschien bei keinem er zwei zwiebeln
eine stange sellerie und 2
knoblauchzehen so alles fertig
geschnittenen knoblauch zwiebeln
karotten sellerie alles sehr fein
geschnitten das wird nämlich zu einer
sauce gleich und die auberginen habe ich
auch kein geschnitten ein bisschen
größer aber unser mit salz gestreut
damit die bitterstoffe entzogen werden
und jetzt wünschen wir das aber hier
trocknet jetzt als zweite mahlzeit
zwischen der parameter also
parlamentarische pizza wir fangen an mit
500 gramm mehl 30 gramm zucker 25 gramm
olivenöl dann lösen wir in 250
milliliter warmen wasser sieben gramm
hefe auf schmeißen die rührmaschine an
lassen dass danach drei stunden lang im
ofen gehen dann packen wir das ganze in
eine backform breites aus und es hat
sich hier den herantasten
etwas olivenöl drin ist jetzt heißen
jetzt warten wieder in 400 gramm
hackfleisch an die andere hälfte ist ob
ich dabei jetzt für unser gemüse darauf
geben wir jetzt wenn das ganze schön
angebraten ist zwei dosen bestätigte
marten und ein wenig grün
und so lassen wir das ganze jetzt
einfach für eine stunde köcheln
also ein bisschen runter mit der hitze
und wind beziehungsweise 1000
verschiedene andere dinge machen wir
sehr wenige drei gerichte auf einmal wir
bereiten jetzt auch den belag von
unserem system schon also von unserer
parlamentarischen pizza vor dafür
schneide ich einfach vier oder fünf
jahren hätte ich jetzt besteht habe das
bibeln in bringe sorry falls ich es
heute ein bisschen anders ist das video
aber noch so viel was ich berücksichtigt
muss ein berg zu machen muss dass ich
einfach sehr konzentriert bin und das
alles ein bisschen kreuz und quer aber
ich bereite mal unseren käse vor
das ist ein ko cavallo so ein bisschen
was von familien und mozzarella und zwar
schneide ich den in würfelchen oder vor
probierst du ein bisschen die sparer
abzubekommen
die andere hälfte behalte ich mir mal
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
von dem katalog asse reden
es geht wieder weiter mit unserer pascal
hornung und zwar habe ich hier ein wenig
kopf schinken nehme ich einfach zu ihnen
ja würfel schneiden zu 150 gramm und das
erledigt ist gebe ich dem mit zu unserer
soße und dazu kommen erste positive von
bisschen angetaut gibt einmal so 100
gramm pro 100 gramm dazu zählen zb ford
auch da gebe ich auch ein wenig olivenöl
hinein dem doch bereiten wir jetzt quasi
das topping für die pizza bord ich nenne
da macht pizza ich glaube damit kann
jeder mehr anfangen kann das übrigens
auch nicht also keine schande wenn es
nicht kennen dann gehen wir in das öl
weil es heiß ist ein paar sardellen wir
kommen ihrem biss ihm ins bett und
stückchen löchern
aber um das öl schon bisher mit
geschmack zu impfen und dazu kommen
jetzt unsere zwiebeln die zwiebeln
kommen wir hier drin jetzt einfach ein
bisschen beide und nicht an braten kann
nicht sondern einfach nur weich werden
machen die hinten jetzt auch schnell
entwickelte fertig 400 milliliter milch
rhein märkt schon langsam wird es
unübersichtlich ich habe jetzt noch eine
weitere panne in der wehr dich gleich
die auberginen frittieren hier sieht
alles so weit gut aus ich gebe jetzt mal
zur mädchen fingen an zu kochen die sich
150 gramm butter dazugeben wir wenig
muskatnuss
ich gebe zwei esslöffel mehl dazu kommt
dass du dich unter ja nicht dass es
mittagessen bin auf jeden fall kurz
kommt ich kenne das durch mich jetzt
auch die zwiebeln hier vorne eine dose
geschälte tomaten ich habe davor
geschaut was die zwiebeln so schön habt
schaut dass die zwiebeln so schön weich
sind und alles gut läuft und ich habe
mir diesen riesigen topf dann kaufe ich
ein bisschen wasser auf und wir geben
jetzt die pasta in den kopf steht drauf
13 minuten wir machen jetzt vielleicht
zu acht weil es kommen aber für eine
halbe stunde hin offen so die mühle sind
jetzt fertig an gekocht stütze jetzt ab
dass nämlich so eine weite von der soße
dem weg zur seite und der rest würde
mich die nudel vermischt
sie bleibe aber so richtig zug drin das
vermisse ich das einmal gut
das sieht schon gut aus jetzt wurde ich
immer alles ran zum belegen jetzt nehmen
wir uns mal die hälfte unserer pasta
warten hier auf dem boden aus ein
bisschen von unseren büffelmozzarella
gehen wir noch ein wenig frischen kann
man sagen drauf so dass ihn selbst über
bergmann wird auch der rest unserer
pasta
das war gut dass wir zur seite getan
hatten unsere vision erst dann kommt der
restliche mozzarella oben drüber und
dann reiben wir jede menge parmesan
drüber
die pasta kommen jetzt für 30 minuten in
den hof die rest von unserem special
der teig die meisten kellereien und in
die löcher komplexen bisschen käse und
sat 1 geben wir auch unseren kontinent
oder ob es hat nicht zu lange gedauert
weil es ist schon angetrocknet auf jeden
fall was sollte auf jeden fall trotzdem
gleich beim backen schön aufnehmen
ihr seht hier ist schon unser krämer
rüberkommen jetzt semmelbröseln bisschen
der gemahlene käse expertise und das
kommt jetzt auch in den ofen
[Musik]
maxim überbackenes alles wer fährt
begeht man so gar kein besteck tja und
wenn nicht gleich welche kabel taucht
plötzlich das mit den titeln auf ja
jetzt gesehen ich war dann aufgeben ich
habe nur das augen gesehen aber wir
sehen uns leicht wieder und es wird zeit
für den zweiten gang das braucht zeit
für den nächsten gang bei unseren oz
finch anissimow jetzt will eigentlich
das bisher kommen aber gucken was
passiert ist ich hatte zitronensorbet
gemacht und habe das in den mixer
gegeben und dachte alles wäre super
[Musik]
doch dann ist alles aus dem thermomix
rausgelaufen
irgendwas hat sich drin gelöst und jetzt
läuft das einfach raus mein ganzes sowie
ja deshalb gibt es jetzt nur zwei gänge
ist mir sehr leid für dich bei porsche
also solltest du das ist mir auch sehr
leid satzgewinn meine ich habe alles
schon fertig hat ist nur noch die
eismaschine erhalten wir sind alles am
ende muss das passiert wirklich nervig
der thermomix ist einfach sport gegangen
aber wir sind gerüstet
es ist sowieso also wie hat denn diesen
mehr videos etwas dann vorlauf also vom
geschmack her ich würde sagen ja 10.10
das war perfekt vom geschmack her kann
ich nichts sagen
vom aussehen konsistenz nur so ist
sollte normalerweise viel kompakter sein
viel fester sein ja und die knusprige
das war nicht so der fall
aber egal weil es hat geschmeckt
deswegen ich würde sagen okay aber für
insgesamt müsste dem mittagessen eine
note aa also tat sowie handschuhe musst
du auch noch dazu alles zusammen ja
unsere city muss schauen wir bei der
titan
ich habe ihn auch wieder top ich will ja
auch ihnen auch einen neuen geben
deswegen heute für das ganze mittagessen
hier das ganze geplant sagt ich würde in
einer hineingehen
dafür ist ob dies machbar glaube das
wäre stato auf das sauwetter dich sagen
wir machen
wir haben schon darüber gesprochen wir
machen irgendwann ein eigenes video ich
mache das beste serie der welt dann
hörst du auf deine kosten hier auch und
wir sprechen jetzt zum artisten naja was
soll ich sagen eigentlich war nicht
geplant diesen part im voice over zu
machen aber das mikrofon ist
abgeschmiert ich habe drei schalotten
fein gewürfelt öl heiß gemacht
charlotten rhein gegeben 400 gramm
risotto reis mit angeschwitzt das ganze
glasig werden lassen weißwein drauf
gegeben
den ganzen weiß wären verkochen lassen
dann habe ich 400 milliliter wasser heiß
gemacht brühe dazu und das aufgeschüttet
dann ein wenig safran dazu dann habe ich
das risotto eindecken lassen 50 gramm
butter dazu parmesan pfeffer salz und
auf einem backblech ausgebreitet damit
es schneller abkühlt dann habe ich drei
liter öl in einem topf heiß gemacht und
habe das kalt geworden und die sorte zu
einem faden geformt dann käse in die
mitte gemacht google geschlossen
sozusagen die han china und das mit
allen weiteren wiederholt insgesamt fünf
stück hatte ich dann pannierstraße
erstmal normales mail dann geschlagene
eier und pankow brett kramp also diese
sushi brett kramp das ganze ins heiße öl
gegeben und für acht minuten frittiert
[Musik]
ball aufgegessen presse aufgegriffen und
ich habe gehört dass es denen sich ganz
schlecht geschmeckt hat
also ich sage ich gebe ihnen direkt 2010
das ist perfekt das ist egal
das schmeckt genauso garantiere ich vor
einem jahr in palermo greifen wir haben
sollte dass irgendwas größte lob das man
bekommen kann also ich liebe ja wirklich
keine bibliothek echten test gemacht was
man von den besonders gut daran also
erfüllt und alles perfekt so richtig
lecker auf viel käse und ich liebe es
gibt keinen sieger natürlich selbst
gemischt
die coolste also garantiert hier
normalerweise in deutschland probiert
haben service getestet wir waren
natürlich nie so wie die echten auch
weil mir gefällt ist für mich das
wichtigste der austritt und dann hat es
dank der daten meines lebens für mein
magen dadurch wir sagen es hat echt spaß
gemacht auch wenn ich jetzt sogar von
lüge und profile glaube ich was den ganz
und da von morgens bis abends gekocht
war echt cool ich konnte meine palette
ausbauen und wir sind uns spätestens
nächsten sonntag nach marx tor maxim